- C'est une image devenue
courante ces dernières semaines:
pharmacies de plusieurs régions
du pays. Ici, en Mauricie.
La pénurie de médicaments
se poursuit.
pharmacienne-propriétaire
- Là, ce qu'on vit, c'
tous nos sirops pour la toux,
pour la grippe, nos comprimés
capables de rien se procurer.
On reçoit ça àp p p de cinq,
six boîtes une fois de temps
en temps. Ça dure 24 heures
c'est déjà vide.
LaLaLa production n'est pas
en cause, mais plutôt
un système d'approvisionnement
et une demande qui a explosé.
BERTRAND BOLDUC, président,
Ordre des pharmaciens du Québec
- C'est lié à une
probablement utilisé trois à
quatre fois plus ddididicaments
contre le rhume et la grippe
cette année qu'habituellement.
par des achats de panique
et le stockage
Il faut examiner des facteurs
atténuants pour une meeeee
gestion des approvisionnements,
estime l'Associationenenenenene.
Ils sont nombreux à demander
à Ottawa de se doter
d'une stratégie.
... indique l'Association
des pharmaciens du Canada.
Les pharmaciens suggè
notamment de tenir une liste de
tous les médicaments essentiels
et de les mosasasasasans arrêt
pour augmenter la production
nationale oumpmpmpmpmpmpmpmpmpma
des risques de pénurie
plutôt que d'attendre que
les étagères soient vides.
Le ministre fédéral de S S S Sn
de près et que son bureau et
Santé Canada sont en discussanaa
et à l'étranger.
Le problème n'est toutefoistst,
la F l l l l la Grande-Bretagne
rapportent aussi des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en pharmacie
de maladies respiratoiress s s .
Ici Camille Feireisen